economic security economic and national  security our Economic Security the  economic and national security of our  country the economic security of knowing  economic security guardians of economic  security  protect Britain from this debt storm  debt storm debt storm debt storm  it is a hard road it is a hard road is  hard but we are making progress making  progress we are making program  taking the difficult decisions more  difficult decisions taking the difficult  decisions very difficult decisions take  the difficult decisions difficult  decisions we have taken difficult  decisions we fix that roof when the sun  is shining we will fix the roof when the  sun is shining is working long-term  economic plan long-term economic plan a  long-term economic plan long-term  economic plan the you hope